[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood snyderman
and who else woke up saying hallelujah
knowing that this beautiful nightmare
would be unleashed on the multiverse
zack snyder's justice league is finally
here and the bill has been wrong that
will mean there's almost no going back
for dc
every fan is giving every other fan a
reach around but there's still work to
be done
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the overall plot of the
film
and discuss what could be happening next
i've compiled lots of behind the scenes
information
the original storyboards for the justice
league sequels as well as the plans for
ben affleck's solo batman movie to
provide you with as
comprehensive of a breakdown on what
could be happening if dc decide to
continue in this direction
which spoiler alert they should if you
enjoyed the video then please click the
thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into this spoiler cut
millennia ago darkseid attempted to
invade
earth throughout the galaxy the evil
entity had conquered many planets
but he came across a force he was not
expecting
a world united together the heroes of
earth joined forces to battle darkseid
and halt him from unleashing a
cataclysmic event known as the unity
this involved synchronizing three mother
boxes which when brought together would
destroy the planet's surface
and turn the majority of the population
into parademons
however earth managed to stop darkseid
and he retreated to the stars
the free people of earth took the mother
boxes and divided them amongst the men
amazonians and atlanteans each race was
responsible for safeguarding them
and they lay hidden over the centuries
that was
until the death of superman upon being
killed by doomsday
his cry sent a signal across the planet
that awakened the mother boxes
and they called out the mother boxes
have three evil spirits within them
and these quote-unquote witches have
been present in several of our myths and
stories
including hercules and macbeth they are
power
and are some of the most dangerous items
in the universe
steppenwolf a long cast out servant of
darkseid heard their call
and he ventured to earth attempting to
complete the unity in order to gain
favor with his master
bruce wayne and diana two defenders i i
sound so epic talking like this don't i
i'll i'll talk like i'm not reading from
a trailer script now
now batman and wonder woman united the
league in order to stop steppenwolf
and along with arthur curry aka aquaman
victor stone the cyborg and barry allen
who goes by the name the flash
they resurrected superman and put an end
to the invasion
during the cataclysmic finale a boom
tube was opened
bridging the earth with apocalypse and
darkseid waited on the other end until
his new kingdom was ready
the unity was actually completed and
earth was almost fully transformed into
a barren wasteland
however barry allen traveled back in
time to moments before
and he helped to send cyborg into the
mother boxes in order to separate them
here he was greeted by an illusion
brought on by the evil entities that
lived within the boxes
and these tempted him with a way to
return to normal and be united with his
family
cyborg rejected this separated the boxes
with the help of superman
and on the outside the league killed
steppenwolf with diana beheading him as
he was tossed through the boom tube
realizing that earth had defenders that
would pose a threat to him
darkseid halted the invasion and
disappeared quicker than amberhead's
accent
with the sad they started to plan
another attack in order to get the
anti-life equation
and slowly they would head to earth
through the stars in order to get it
this is obviously a huge addition that
we'll talk about in just a bit
but another big change in the film is
the scene which involves lex luthor and
deathstroke meeting on the former's
yacht
before deathstroke can even say i'm on a
boat lex reveals that bruce wayne is
batman
i was so surprised that this was cut as
during production of even justice league
ben affleck's batman's script was being
worked on so maybe there were behind the
scenes things that we don't know about
the moment was of course parodied at the
end of birds of prey
but it of course brings a lot with it
now the original plan for the batman
solo film
involved deathstroke is the villain
according to joe manchinello
the film was very similar to the game a
psychological thriller and not the
naughtiest rapper
the game though the beef they have is
worse than the one he did with 50 cent
i digress though now that stroke was
going to systematically destroy bruce's
life bit by bit
and not only would he ruin his companies
he would also dismantle his
relationships and everything he'd built
as the dark knight
so no more reach-arounds manchinalos
stated that he would be like a shark in
many ways
swimming beneath the surface and slowly
stalking bruce before he made his move
now the vendetta against bruce though
not confirmed
is likely the same one that deathstroke
had against the teen titans
in the comics the villain believed that
they were responsible for the death of
his son
and due to batman's cavalier attitude
when it comes to dropping cars on people
it's possible that he may have taken his
life now that's just me guessing but the
fact that deathstroke says it's a
personal vendetta
that leads to him shutting down
everything in bruce's life it makes me
think they're pulling heavily on the
comics
lex jokes about it being an eye for an
eye referencing his missing one
and it is even possible that in the dc
eu batman was responsible for taking
his out this was meant to be the next
release with the dark knight in it
and from there we would travel to
justice league 2 which saw lex forming
the legion of doom
these storyboards that contained the
outline were displayed in the justice
league exhibit
but warner brothers have been flagging
posts containing them so i don't want to
risk putting them here
however they should still be online if
you want to give it a quick google
go yeah i'm not your dad in addition to
this there are a couple of changes here
and there from the ending
and though martian manhunter makes a big
appearance at the end of the film
he spars throughout the original plan
now that plan for justice league 2 was
to continue down this dark timeline
in which joss whedon's version was canon
and 2021 was just 2020 new game plus
wait isn't that what it is anyway this
initially started off with like setting
up the legion of doom
but it expanded far beyond that lex met
with dr maru from wonder woman who had
prolonged her life similar to diana
by experimenting on herself with certain
chemicals he also burst
orm and black manta out of their prisons
and freed leonard snot
aka captain cold who he would have been
introduced to in the flash
he would also meet shock horror the
riddler
who we learned told lex batman's true
identity
lex was very much following the arc that
bruce did in this film
and the dark knight was desperate to
stop him there was a lot of action
scenes between the legion and the league
but i feel like the main driving force
is lex's true quest
in the film bruce and lois teamed up to
track him down
and during this bruce started to suspect
that she was keeping something from him
now the original plan was to have lois
and bruce actually have a relationship
during the time that superman was dead
and she felt pregnant
this was hinted at in one of the snyder
cut scenes in which she had a pregnancy
test in her draw
the pair got into an argument during
this moment and lois told bruce that he
wasn't the father
whilst she stormed out of the cave now
batman slowly tracked down the riddler
and discovered that lex came to him with
the anti-life equation
and he managed to solve it this was the
greatest riddle of all time
and after unlocking it lex now had
within his grasp
the ability to control all life itself
but he wanted to serve lex stole the
mother boxes
and activated them which brought forth
darkseid through a boon tube
lex bowed before him and darkseid took
the anti-life equation and started to
enact his plan
elsewhere in the batcave superman lois
and bruce became aware that darkseid was
on earth
and supes volunteered to go and fight
him as he was the only one capable of
stopping the villain
he said to bruce protector she's my
world and headed towards the villain
now it's at this point in the original
plan that darkseid revealed he didn't
want to kill superman
instead he wanted him to submit lex
revealed that lois was the key to
breaking his spirit
and darkseid boom tube to the bat cave
which is where he killed her within a
maker beam
batman looked on during all of this
horrified unable to act before it
happened
and like superman he watched the person
he loved die
before his very eyes superman returned
and
this is a shot that we see in the snyder
cut with him cradling lois's skeleton in
his arms
due to him losing his home earth his
wife and child superman was just
completely broken
and with the anti-life equation darkseid
was able to corrupt him
across the world lex unleashed his plan
and the legion of doom
slaughtered the league darkseid ventured
across the planet helping to kill wonder
woman
and aquaman and cyborg and flash barely
managed to escape
which we'll talk about in just a bit now
bruce has a battle during this with
superman
but he managed to get out of the cave
with his life intact
superman then went to lex and burned him
alive with his laser beams
we then had a five-year time jump to the
nightmare sequence
which showed batman and the surviving
group of heroes
fearful of dark side in superman now the
following film one from this
actually opened with green lantern
crashing on earth after this five year
time jump
i'm not sure whether this is sam
benjamin who was originally meant to be
gl
or if it's killerwork who we see in the
destroyed hall of justice during the
nightmare timeline
zack did confirm with the hollywood
reporter that he wanted ryan reynolds to
play some part amongst the lanterns too
so there were a lot of different options
either way after being saved by batman
greenland became our eyes and ears on
what had happened in between the time
jump
over the five years cyborg had helped to
create a cosmic treadmill that would
allow flash to journey back in time
however this could only be attempted
once a year as the earth had to be in
the same spot as the treadmill
otherwise flash might materialize in the
middle of a rock or something
but doing this would give him a brief
window of 10 to 15 seconds before he was
torn apart
in which he could deliver a message to
bruce to hopefully change things
now i've sort of changed things myself
here using the snyder cup more
as cannon as originally they never met
joker
and it was dead shot instead of
deathstroke zach has also gone on to add
it that he likes the idea of a last
supper moment
in which joker and batman will discuss
the death of robin and we will get
flashbacks to what really happened
the bare bones are about the same but i
just thought i'd add that in as you
don't know how things are going to
change if if they get pushed into
production
which they better yeah hashtag restore
the snyder verse i want that trending
now
they debate over what to tell the past
with them initially settling on saying
stop lex
this is because if they stop lex then he
can't hand over the anti-life equation
and so on and so forth however bruce has
had a change of heart
and whispers something to barry that we
don't get revealed until later on
in order to power the treadmill up they
must steal a mother box
and they journey to the joker who has
managed to secure one
this is what we see in the epilogue of
the film and superman lands before
fighting the league
deathstroke tries to use a kryptonite
bullet on him but this fails and the man
of steel kills him
he also rips mira in half as she tries
to suck the moisture out of his body
and he fires his laser beams at the
green lantern's ring which cause it to
explode
and blow off his arm the rest of the
group make a mad dash to the cave
and here they power up the treadmill
flash journeys back to the bat cave
namely the moment that dark side
appeared in it to kill lois
he finds bruce frozen and tara and says
she lied to you
you are the father before he's torn
apart bruce throws himself in front of
darkseid's omega beam
and he saves lois superman arrives in a
rage
but instead of being broken he's
empowered he puts darkseid on the back
foot
and the villain retreats which is when
lois reveals that she's discovered lex's
plan
something she never got to say in the
original timeline
bruce realizes that though he survived
the omega beams
something corrupted him inside and he
doesn't have long to live
and therefore decides to sacrifice
himself bruce says to lois he could have
had a life outside the cave with her
but it wasn't meant to beak now this
sacrifice of course calls back to what
joker said to him at the end of the
snyder cut
namely all of the bad timelines that are
caused because he refuses to lay down
his life
this time he's willing to and across the
world the heroes come together to stop
the legion of doom from destroying
aquaman and diana
as the pair of figureheads in their
respective kingdoms they're able to
unite the amazonians with the atlanteans
together they form an allegiance with
the people of the surface
and the world itself becomes somewhat of
a justice league
darkside launches his invasion with the
earth coming together to stop him
and batman sacrifices himself in order
to kill the villain
in the end the world mourns his death
and though clark fields her that the
child is not his
he does come to accept it we then jump
forward 20 years and see
lois meeting with commissioner gordon
who tells her that crime is rising in
gotham
he asks her what she's going to tell her
child and we follow her as she takes us
into the bat cave
to reveal that his dad was bruce wayne
the son becomes the batman which
ends the film i'm not kidding that is
exactly what was in the original
storyboards now snyder has stated that
he has drawn up a new one for justice
league too but i think because of the
way that it was set up at the end of
this film
that it would sort of follow along the
same lines i think some things would
have been changed and i'm a bit unsure
on the lowest in bruce relationship
as not only did bruce [ __ ] up superman
he also [ __ ] his girl
shabao you know how i like to do it
nothing elements like that would have
been tweaked
and shout out to emma underscore louise
19 on twitter for pointing out that lois
is carrying a baby basket at the end of
the snyder cut
bruce also says congratulations by the
way
making me think that clark is the dad
but we don't know yet
we would have also likely got more
martian manhunter and ryan choi
in case you don't know ryan choi is
actually the adam in the comics
in the end of the scidaca it's revealed
that he's heavily involved with nanotech
which of course centers around micro
machines
not them kind of micro machines though
shout out to micro machines yeah
now whatever happens to ryan it looks
like they were setting up the hero
within the dc eu
and potentially he would have been
involved in other projects so lots of
things to talk about but as for this
movie itself i have to say i absolutely
loved it
i've now watched it four times and i
feel like it's such an improvement on
the theatrical cut
i can't understand why this was scrapped
in favor of that
a mustache why warner brothers did this
but i'm so glad that they realized their
error and put this out
the film was amazing for me and i
absolutely love the new material
final hour and added character
development which just gives
so much more to the movie i found the
first hour a bit slow but that's likely
because it plays on the same foundations
of scenes that we've seen before
but beyond that this is a complete
improvement in every way
other than some of the music choices i
feel but don't don't at me on that
a steppenwolf in my opinion is far more
interesting
cyborg has gone from being a boring
robot to my favorite character in the
film
and every single person gets a far more
expanded arc that i really appreciate it
the score is better there's a lot less
plot holes the action dwarfs it
and sets up so much for the future that
i want to see more
i think people have been fighting for
this movie will now feel vindicated
as it's an amazing release and if you're
a fan of snyder then you're gonna
absolutely love it
i'm gonna go for another re-watch and
i'm sure you are too
sorry thanks for thanks for spending
some time with me
we better head out now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the movie
and if you want to see this universe
continue or not comment below and let me
know and as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k boxset of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our review of
the film as a whole which will be linked
on
screen right now this was sort of an
ending explain this video yet whereas
that's sort of
more of my opinion on things so
definitely give it a watch after this
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace